this is where friendship comes into play
with the different figures that
are loosely associated with idw is you
are somehow
uh responsible for
you know the the exactly thing that you
said did you hear what
i don't know i forgive the dame oh who
what sam harris said about
idw yeah uh that that kind of thing is
why chuckled lovingly or
chuckle like or i was angry at some
people
who had said things that caused sam to
say what sam said about
turning his imaginary club membership
into the idw
people said very silly things and
you know i think that there is just this
confusion that
um integrity means calling out your
friends
in in in front of the world right and
you know i've been pretty clear about
this
i try to choose my friends carefully and
if you would like to recuse me
because i'm not a source of reliable
information people that i know and love
the most
um maybe that's reasonable for you maybe
you'd prefer somebody who was willing to
throw a friend under the bus at the
first sign of trouble
by all means exit my feed you don't have
to subscribe to me if that's
if that's your concept of integrity
you're barking up the wrong tree what i
will say is that i knew these people
well enough to know that they're all
flawed
thank you for the call back and uh but
the issue is
that um i love people who are flawed
and i love people who have to earn a
living
even if you call them a grifter and i
love people who
you know like the fact that donald trump
didn't get us into new wars even if you
call them alt-right
i love the fact that some people believe
in
structural oppression and want to fight
it even if they're not woke
because they don't believe that
structural oppression is hiding
everywhere
i care and love different people in
different ways and i just
i think that you know the overarching
thing lacks that we're not getting at is
that
we were sold a bill of goods that you
can go through life
like an eliza program with
pre-programmed
responses well it's what about ism
it's both scientism it's all right
it's the loony left it's campus madness
you know it's like
okay why don't you just empty the entire
goddamn
magazine all
of those pre-recorded
snips now that you've done
all of that now we can have a
conversation
your son put it really well which is we
should in all things resist labels
but we can't deal without labels we have
to generalize
but we also have to keep in mind that
just the way in science you deal with an
effective theory that isn't a
fundamental one
in science most of our theories we
consider to be effective theories
if i generalize about about europe
about women about
you know christians those things
have to be understood to mean something
and not
to have their definitions extend so
broadly that they mean
nothing at all nor
that they're so rigid that their claims
that clearly won't bear scrutiny
you